lisa is with us in wyoming hi Lisa how
are you good how are you doing better
than I deserve
Merry Christmas what's up Merry
Christmas well my mom co-signed about -
six years ago on student loans when I
was going out going to college at a
university out-of-state and she now
recently come up where it's probably two
or three times a week that she called me
and wants me to get her off as a
cosigner and at this point I don't have
okay and that's what I've tried to tell
me I just her next solution was to get a
loan from a bank so I don't know really
where to go with the conversation so
what do you what do you what what are
you - Oh on this loans on these loans
right under 25,000 okay and what do you
make I'm actually a stay-at-home mom
okay my husband made which area I still
working on that I'm going to school for
special education and elementary
education so there's nothing being paid
on the loans right now I we're making
payments my husband is just to keep some
of the payments down like Sheamus now
Mike what does your husband make a year
we write a little over a hundred
thousand okay and how much other dad
other than 22-thousand do you have not
counting your house probably twenty-five
so fifty grand gets you out of that and
you make a hundred yes and you're paying
for school also yeah okay
and you plan to fit when you finish the
degree you plan to go to work yeah right
away okay and how much do you like
finishing the degree daddy year at you
okay and if you're gonna go to work when
you finish the degree
why are you not working now I recently
decided to quit my job and with the
money that I was making as a special ed
aid was paying for insurance and daycare
and so my husband got a job with
insurance and I decided to stay home so
you weren't making enough to even cover
the costs of you working not really
sorry but getting your degree in that
field will allow you to make more yeah
they start off teachers here like 46,000
first-year teachers okay
well aside from your mom's request
number one if you guys can get a bank
loan and you want to get a bank loan you
can there's nothing wrong with that
okay that's up to you if you want to do
that and if you can do that probably a
better plan would be let's just pay it
off in a year let's get on beans and
rice rice and beans you figure out some
stuff you can do while you're at home
that generates some income and okay and
let's do more and let's get on a really
really tight written budget and you and
your husband start looking around going
what have we got to do to get out of
this debt and you know let's plus let's
knock off the 22,000 I think you could
have her her off of this and you offer
this in one year I know should we move
that up on our baby steps or no well no
I mean you you only have two debts I
thought
22 and 25 the other I have the 25 and
then the other is like student loans
from his degree and credit card and oh
so that's not your only dad no so it's
not 22 and 25 bigger no okay I ask you
what your other debts other than your
house was and I got 22 and 25 what else
is there just one credit card that we're
working on
we have my car payment what are you own
as far I want to say 22 or no not 22 and
$10,000 on your car okay and so you have
a $10,000 go ahead I'm sorry we pay we
get we have cattle so our cattle from
our calves check
goes to the loans every year plus
monthly - Oh money on your cattle no it
goes on what loan our car payment
oh okay long okay come what is your
cattle worth if you sold them all today
um probably a hundred not even a hundred
thousand thirty five yeah some 1000
someone okay and let's clean your debts
up okay and then aside from that okay so
that we got 35 to throw at these debts I
got 22 I got 25 I got 10 on a car and
then there was about what would you say
how would you sound the credit card 800
800 from nothing okay alright yeah and
so if we sell the the if I got it right
there's four debts is therefore debts
yes a car what's the 25 we have 25 for
my sumo oh he has like 10,000 three
months also okay all right and what's
okay so ten thousand on a car ten
thousand on his student loans twenty-two
on your student loans eight hundred on a
credit card and then you mentioned 25
what is that
my students are the 25 they're not 22
okay so there's not a twenty two twenty
no it's just the canoe ones combined
okay so let me try again
alright so you owe 25 on student loans
he owes 10 you owe ten on a car and 800
on a credit card is there anything else
okay and so that's $45,000 $35,000 where
the cattle pays off almost everything
okay and you'll have her paid off and be
debt-free very very quickly making a
hundred yeah that's what I'm doing and
that's not because of her request it's
because it's a smart thing for you guys
to do
to get out of debt because effectively
if you line it up on a balance sheet
assets on one side liabilities on the
other it's as if you have borrowed on
student loans to buy cattle because
instead of paying off your student loans
you bought cattle we had my husband has
had those since he was six okay very
mathematically it is as if since one is
on asset and one is a liability on a
balance sheet if you list two columns
you know assets on one side liabilities
on the other debts and things you can
sell on the other when you compare them
against each other mathematically it is
the same thing so I'm going to sell all
of his sweet little cows and he can get
him some cows later when you guys are
debt-free and he makes more money and
you make more money and your mom is not
calling you about a co-signed loan that
you should have already paid off and so
yeah let's get it cleared up let's get
it done